this is Startalk so your question is
what oh your video alright so the
question is if you're stretching yeah
then there's one point in between it's
not stretching in that way or the other
to make an end of string I like this
that's my best argument so so we leave
it in a UFO on a spaceship and we're
going we leave for a year
yeah I just feel like yeah okay when I
come back how and then he sees my age
yeah
he's 50 yeah and I left for a year at
the speed of light when I come back how
old is he how old am i he's 51 and
you're still 15 you ain't a fraction of
a second the faster you go the less you
age relative to him so if you won wait
for two years yeah then he's 52 you're
still 50 you went away for 50 years he's
a hundred and probably dead and you're
still 50 so that's the problem with
traveling fast yeah because you leave
all your loved ones behind and none of
them are alive when you return so what
if you're going triple the speed of life
well you so you can well we don't know
anyway to do that let me say it another
way we don't know how to pass through
the speed of light keep going but if you
stick speeds hmm that exist faster than
the speed of light in the equations you
end up moving backwards through time
yeah so you'd end up you you could send
yourself a message that you would
receive before you actually sent it okay
so they think
so you went faster than the speed of
light you go better so no backwards and
we hypothesized of the vertical well the
tachyon yeah from the from the Greek
root tachyons like a tachometer same
route of the word so tachyons would
exist faster than the speed of light and
so we imagine if they existed could you
could someone in the future be
communicating with us trying to tell us
what to look what to not do so many more
sounds so so but we love for technology
we've never found me so I think the
whole universe well so this is
interesting notion because stars are
born they live out their lives they die
and they spawn other stars that's what
life does on earth right that they have
a metabolism they make kind of colonies
and so maybe our definition of life
itself is is needlessly restricted to
just what's going on on our respective
earth well so here's one of the things
that I Baskin you know the people say we
didn't land on the moon you know why
there because they can't they refuse to
believe that technology could have
gotten there and what an amazing time we
live in that the technology is so great
that some people among us are in denial
and that's what to me that's what's
amazing to me
so but I mean like you dial a number
yeah it bounces goes through the walls
an elevator
office power they those to a satellite
want me to get the satellite for the
timing but the GPA the corneas GPS who
goes through satellite they're just
calling somebody goes to towers tower to
tell never makes a mistake it always get
the right person basically there's no
right then the smart people are
programming so folks where does it how
does it how does it know because there
are 25 different discoveries and physics
to make the smart phone how does it go
through the air using microwaves they go
through walls new ones
dozens of discoveries in physics
discover my physicists not thinking
about it they make a discovery and if
the principal is there the clever
engineers articulate
I mean his microwave microwave maybe a
liar they're dead spots - cell phones go
oh because you're not near enough to
towers for the strength of your signal
you can actually work
so that's what this will say about the
coverage by the way more expensive I'll
tell you about
this is Startalk